Speaker 1: All right, I have for you today
some of the funniest video I've seen come
out of the political world for at least a
day or two, know for at least several months
to Republican members of Congress.
Matt Gates currently under investigation for
a litany of possible crimes.
And Marjorie Taylor Green, A. Masque anti
vax congresswoman who regularly compares things
to the Holocaust and then apologizes for doing
it and then does it again.
They tried to hold a press conference.
Now, the press conference was meant to be
think about this in defense of the January
6th, Trump rioters in defense of the rioters,
not the police, Gates and Green, who normally
claim to be all about supporting the troops
and supporting the police.
Gates and Green apparently believe.
That the defendants, the accused rioters,
are being treated too harshly by our legal
system in terms of their detentions and the
like.
This is not an issue they have any other time
except when you have exclusively Trump supporters
having been the alleged perpetrators.
Now, all of a sudden, they care about the
harsh treatment of these defendants by the
justice system.
So they hold this press conference and imagine
that being your primary concern related to
the January 6th riots instead of actually
investigating what happened and who incited
it.
But that's their position.
So they try to hold a press conference.
When I say try, I say that because it goes
hilariously off the rails when protesters
shut it down with screaming and whistles.
And our friend Lauren Windsor asking Matt
Gates on repeat whether whether he's a pedophile.
Let's get into the first clip.
And the funniest part of this one is it gets
shut down.
And Louie Gohmert, a wacky Republican congressman,
he sort of tries to just keep going, but nobody
cares.
Once Gates and Green start leaving, nobody
even listens to Louis.
Take a look at this.
It's everything about it is perfect.
Speaker 2: The people of this country to get
the answers to the questions we need.
And we need a break.
And we need to the at interrupting the press
conference, we need to thank you for those
of you that really, Carol, is just amazing.
Speaker 1: The Whistler interrupts the press
conference.
Louie Gohmert tries to speak, but it's just
too late.
Nobody cares.
Everybody's just leaving.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
Ladies and gentlemen, what you just saw here
today is, again, the intolerant left
Speaker 1: and that the voice you heard there
is, I guess, an anchor of some kind for the
YouTube channel, right side broadcasting network.
So the whistles are just absolutely fascinating.
The entire thing gets shut down.
Here is here's another clip of the Whisler
really preventing this from even from even
getting going.
I mean, it's really incredible.
Got.
So that's actually the whisler in the yellow
shirt, if people are watching right in front
of the right side, broadcasting anchor just
whistling and whistling,
Speaker 2: you're going OK?
No, they're not.
Speaker 1: All right.
Now I'm against hearing loss and doing anything
that's going to force hearing loss on people.
Of course, I think it is important to remember
that, you know, there is an onus on if you
want to hold a press conference in public,
then there's the possibility that because
it's in public, people are going to show up.
I think that it starts to get over the line
if you blow the whistle really loud right
in someone's ear, I'm right there on that.
But the same way that you are choosing to
speak in a public place.
People can choose to yell or blow a whistle
in a public place as well.
And then it all I mean, just the level of
derailment is crazy.
Let's look at one more of these clips
Speaker 2: trying to be creative.
Are you trying to show with auditory
Speaker 1: it's a weapon now.
Now, this there were no weapons at the at
the January 6th riots, but the whistle is
a weapon now.
I mean, it's actually quite stunning how much
havoc and chaos one guy with a whistle can
actually wreak at this one event.
OK, so then we get to the point where Marjorie
Taylor Green and Matt Gates, they essentially
just get run out and they start literally
running away with security or staffers or
whoever.
And then this is where there's another layer
to the memetic aspect of this.
Matt Gates start being out, starts to be asked
on repeat whether he's a pedophile.
And it turns out that that's actually Lauren
Windsor, who we as a, you know, a friend of
the show.
Take a look at this
Speaker 2: and we take them away.
Off they go.
Hear the left.
Unidentified: Hey, hey, hey, hey,
Speaker 2: hey, how are you doing?
Why are you getting
Unidentified: hit by a.
Speaker 1: Now, obviously, child sex abuse
and pedophilia is not funny, the image of
Lauren with a huge camp like who even uses
a camera that big anymore, it almost could
be a prop.
And it would add to the comedic element chasing
Gates and saying, are you a pedophile?
Is amazing that we actually have Lauren's
video from Undercurrent with a different view
on this.
Take a look at.
Speaker 2: Are you a pedophile here?
Are you are you out here?
I mean, are you are you are you sure of
Speaker 1: so just absolute and total chaos.
And again, it all goes back to their the whole
point of this press conference was that yesterday
we had the first day of testimony in the House
Select Committee investigating the January
6th riots.
And the reaction from Matt Gates and Marjorie
Taylor Green is, whoa, they're really not
treating the accused rioters very well in
the justice system.
And of course, you and I have been talking
about the fact that too often nonviolent defendants
are held without bail or held with a bail
that's too high for them to make.
So they're stuck in pretrial detention.
They can't mount a defense.
They're unable to make money.
They're unable to parent their kids if they
have kids.
And it just perpetuates the situation.
We've talked about that when it comes to nonviolent
defendants, they now are all of a sudden concerned
about bail being too high or bail being denied
to people accused of actual violence in some
of these cases.
And now all of a sudden, they care and they
want criminal justice reform.
I mean, it's just all completely and totally
pathetic.
And the entire thing getting shut down.
Who knew that?
A whistle.
I mean, listen, I remember being eight.
I remember wreaking havoc with a whistle,
but I was never able to wreak this amount
of havoc.
And it's absolutely fascinating
to see.